um if you sit on that side of the room
or up to about here it's much better
because then i will be able to spot if
you raise your hand and have a question
right um i'll be sitting right here and
then i can see the room i'm going to be
monitoring both the zoom questions and
the questions in the room when you have
a question in the room we've got two
microphones here i'm going to
give one to you so that you can spread
it maybe around uh quickly get it to the
person on this side of the room and i'll
give one to you so that we can quickly
get it here
just raise your hand and i'll call on
you and then uh there are also
microphones in the ceiling so we should
be able to pick up the sound relatively
well for the uh call but so
please despite this sort of format uh
ask questions i think that's what what
this is for okay without further ado
welcome um we talked on the first day
about causal graphs on the second day
about graphical about causal discovery
and so at least part of what thomas is
going to be talking about today uh is
about a somewhat different language of
looking at
a causality namely in terms of potential
outcomes
and i'm very glad that thomas was
willing to do this he's professor of
statistics at the university of
washington thank you thomas for doing it
the floor is yours
great
thank you um
so yeah let me post there was a request
for slides so i'm going to post
the link for the slides into the chat so
just give me one moment to do that
um so here we go
and i'm also going to let me just check
i can do that okay so here's the link
for the slides
um
and i will also make use of a whiteboard
um here is the link for the whiteboard
okay so um
yes so
i was asked to say a couple of remarks
about sort of at a high level and and
essentially
um
at a high level i think all cores and
models are trying to link two things
together they're trying to link together
a world in which we perform an
intervention of some kind and a world
where
we observe a system without performing
interventions
and
this spencer's talk on the first day
introduced causal models in a way that's
very natural from a graphical
perspective where we start off um
with a dag describing the system in the
absence of interventions
and then we then by removing edges come
up with another graph describing the
system after we've
um
after we intervene but it's outcomes in
some ways you can think about them sort
of go the other way around
they
start by thinking about
distributions resulting from
interventions and then work back to um
what what we observe in the absence of
intervention
but i'm trying to make this clearer both
in this lecture and also in the first
lecture this afternoon so what i'm going
to talk about in the next hour is i'm
going to give you a brief history of
causation
talk about potential outcomes
and counter factuals so in the
philosophical literature and and also
some statisticians make a big
distinction between the potential
outcomes in county factories i'm going
to use them synonymously here it's not
um simply
because uh although there are
interesting distinctions to be made
there i don't think they're relevant to
most the points that i'm making here um
i'll then talk about randomized
experiments average causal effects and
observational studies
um
so
yeah so
people have been interested in causal
relationships for a long time
um
this is the sort of uh
um
uh uh
quote from democritus basically saying
you'd rather find a single causal
relationship than the king of persia
um we then jump forwards to
hume um
in his uh inquiry concerning
human understanding he says we may
define a cause to be an object followed
by another where all the objects similar
to the first are followed by objects
similar to the second so in modern uh
terminology he's essentially saying that
if there's a cause we would expect there
to be some sort of um association
um and then
but then obviously
you know there's there's an issue that
immediately arises with that which is
that well
we can think of situations where there's
an association but we wouldn't think of
it as being causal
and so he adds this condition saying
where if the first object had not been
the second never had existed
um so he noticed that i'm writing this
here to indicate he's now not telling
you about what he actually saw what we
would necessarily see but he's telling
us about what we would have seen had
things been different
um
and i also just add to the philosophers
there
who may already know this that this that
hume is sort of famous in philosophy for
three different causal theories um
but um
this isn't one of them potentially
although david lewis i think is
responsible for sort of
popularizing this this particular bit
okay so now we jump forwards to the
start of the 20th century and people are
doing agricultural field trials
where they want to know which seed
varieties produce or cause the greatest
yield or it could also be which
fertilizers
produce the greatest yield
and there's a immediate problem that
arises which is that the plots of land
that these different seeds or varieties
of seed are being tried on are not
are not all the same some of them you
know may
may have more rocks
buried in them some may have better
drainage um
all kinds of things may be going on
and so there's a sort of a
that it's not possible to hold all of
the conditions um constant
and so naaman
spent a lot of time at berkeley but this
is before he spent
time
at berkeley this is his master thesis in
1923
he
came up with this conceptual framework
which in some ways we can think of as
sort of formalizing what uh um hume was
alluding to where he says supposing
we're interested in comparing v
varieties so those could be c's for
example on m plots
then we will consider a set of numbers
a matrix like this
where u i j is the crop yield that would
be observed if variety i were planted in
plot g okay so the key point is
so each one of these little this little
picture over here each one of these sort
of strips we can only plot we can only
plant one
uh crop in each strip
um in general you know that they're um
yeah we can only
plant one crop in each strip because
then
um
you know even if we were to plant a
different crop there the next year the
weather conditions are not going to be
exactly the same and the condition of
the soil is not going to be exactly the
same as on so there's only we can only
the key restriction here is that each
plot can only have one variety planted
in it
um
but conceptually we can think about the
set of numbers so here the set the first
column of numbers here this first number
is the number that we will observe if we
decide to plant variety one in strip one
the bottom number here is the num is the
number that we will observe if we decide
to plant for rtv in strip one
but we will only get to see one
number in that column okay
so that's a physical constraint
so we're only going to see one number
per column
uh and so
so now essentially what what we have is
we have a missing data problem
this is a we have this matrix that
conceptually exists
but uh
we we are only going to be able to see
one number from each columns
okay so now just to take it forwards and
think about a medical exam and also to
simplify it a little bit we're going to
think about we could think about a
randomized controlled trial
with a treatment or drug and a control
or placebo i'm going to use x to
indicate um treatment or control
um and for each patient we're then going
to observe an outcome
why which will either be good eg recover
or bad
die and just to keep things simple to
start with i'll just think about that as
being a binary outcome so binary
treatment binary response
so we've switched from plots in a field
to patients and kilograms of wheat
instead of that being our response we've
now got live or diet that response
okay and um
so
so we've now got um
we've now got uh two
uh random variables that we can think
about defined for each patient y of x
equals zero is the value of y the
outcome that would be observed for that
patient if they were assigned to x
equals zero
and y of x equals one is the value of y
that would be observed for given unit if
assigned x equals one
uh um and so we're writing
so these are two step random variables
so to those of you that are sort of
deeply into probability you might be
thinking of these as sort of uh
realizations and somehow this is you
know like omega so don't think about it
like this think of this as just two
different random variables
um uh defined on the same underlying
sample space so for each patient in our
population very conceptually this there
are two numbers associated with that
patient the outcome that they would have
if they were in the control arm and the
outcome that they would have if they
were in the treatment term
um
okay uh and also this this equal sign
um can takes up certain amount of space
and we're going so for notational
reasons i'm often going to
shorten
y of x equals zero to be y sub uh y of x
sub i so that's a that's a shorthand for
this
so this was this model was due to name
and back in the 1920s but it was
popularized by ruben in in the 1970s and
so it's sometimes called the reuben that
the name in ruben causal model or even
just the rubin cause of model
so i should also let you know if you
read in this lecture um other authors
use slightly different uh notation so
there are other authors that will write
this as y super x equals i or y
subscript x equals i
okay so this is this is where we've got
to at this point we have conceptually
this model here is a very simple little
conceptual data set i've got five
patients and each patient's got their
outcome under control and their outcome
under treatment
and then
the way that the data that we actually
observe gets generated is in a very
natural way we go through and we decide
for each one of our
patients whether or not they're going to
get treatment or control so that gives
us this
column here
and then the observed data the outcomes
that we actually get to see are then
just given by essentially copying across
the entry from the relevant potential
outcome um
set of potential outcomes so here
you know the first patient was assigned
to treatment so then the outcome we
observe for them will be this number
second uh patient is assigned to control
so the outcome we observe for them will
be this number here and so on
okay
so notice here the thing that comes
first are the is this these potential
outcomes and then the observed data is
generated uh uh from them
uh uh by
in this sort of stepwise fashion
and um
so this that there's this property this
could be expressed what i've just shown
you in that table could also be
expressed uh
by this sort of simple formula that just
says that the r observed outcome is
equal to y of x equals 0 if x is 0 and
is equal to y of x equals 1 if x is 1 or
equivalently we could also
we could also write it like this that if
x is equal to little x then y is equal
to y of little x
quick clarification question in the zoom
so in the potential outcome framework
the random variable for the treatment
and control is indexed for a particular
individual
so yeah so basically for each individual
they have two outcomes conceptually
we're only ever going to get to see one
but for each
individual uh it's it's a bivariate
distribution so they they conceptually
will have both um both outcomes that
answer the question
so yeah yeah i saw i saw okay great um
yeah so so so did we have the this is a
little bit tautologous for an individual
who has x equals little x their observed
response y is equal to the response y of
x that would be observed had x be next
but this is a bit unnatural because the
way that we usually usually when we
think of subjunctives
uh you know that there aren't things
that actually happen but but that this
is the meaning of this consistency
okay and so then
uh we can think about in the simplest
case where y is a binary outcome we can
think of a patient as belong to one of
four types
uh if both of their entries are zero
they're of type never recover if you
know if if uh their outcome under
control is is bad but their outcome
under treatment is good then they're
helped and so on
and although i should note here that
again language is a little bit
problematic here that although this
helped and hurt has a kind of and also
never and always has a temporal
connotation but here we're really
thinking across possible worlds so
someone who's helped we mean they're
helped in the sense that if they get
treatment their outcome is better than
it would have been had they got control
um
just speak
basically a typology
of
intrinsic propensities of units like
this to be the type of unit that is
denominated by
never recover
is just to
intrinsic just to be defined by
intrinsic causal propensities which is
you don't respond to the drug
and and then so on and so forth
so
so so what did what uh uh
so the idea is that these people are of
certain types so yes there is some uh um
ontology that's going on here we are
supposing
that each person
is a one of these four types okay so so
essentially it is to say
that
we're only applying the
we're only giving the person treatment
at one point in time and we're seeing
one response uh but we are
um
that we are
um
so somebody who's have never never
recovered it means that in the possible
world where they get given uh treatment
they will not recover and in the
possible world where they get given
control they will not recover so we are
uh positing that each one of these
individuals
has these two types there are
people who will take issue with that
who'll say well you know i don't really
i'm willing to think that
there is an observed outcome when i give
the person whatever i give them but i'm
not really willing to think that there's
a single value that corresponds to what
would have happened to them had they
been in the other
arm because there are too many uh
uncertainties and different ways that
their treatment could have been given
and and ultimately you know there as we
know there are lots of philosophical
questions about uh whether or not um
counterfactual statements are well
defined or whether they are
uh whether it's meaningful um but
on the other hand i think the
from the perspective of somebody
carrying about a randomized controlled
trial
that the reason that it's this is an
appealing way of thinking about it is
there's this moment in time where they
flip the coin
and if it comes up with saying heads
saying you get treatment then
you know there's the world that occurs
downstream from there and then if it
comes up tails and they get control
there's another well-defined world there
so essentially
um
yeah so the issues about whether whether
possible the weather count factors well
defined are
uh are well taken but um this is a
conceptual model i mean whenever
whenever we invoke a probability
distribution there's a conceptual model
that we're
invoking um yeah so i don't know whether
that addresses your question um i'm
sorry actually it doesn't mean to be
annoying but i i actually i'm not sure
if i understand the answer are you
saying that we are just positing that
there is some distribution
of intrinsic types and my internet types
are either defined by virtue of
global productivity needs to be the
treatments so there's just some portion
of people in the population that
will never recover there's some portion
of the people the population that are
susceptible to the job and there's some
people in the population that are lucky
yes okay
okay okay okay sorry thank you
okay maybe i should have said that first
okay
uh so the key point here is
that that the distinction actually
potential outcome so um yeah just to add
a note here i think the word propensity
there prevents the is an overloaded term
and so that was why
uh yeah that was why
i didn't just say yes
okay
okay
so the key distinction here is x is the
treatment the given patient gets and
thus far i haven't said anything about
whether it's randomly assigned could
result from doctoral patient choices
um y is the observed response for a
given patient
and then y of x is the response that
would be observed for a given patient if
possibly counter the fact they received
x equals x
okay these are our basic objects
fundamental problem of causal inference
is that we only get to see each person
under one
treatment regime so this is going to be
our observed data we're not going to see
the entries that don't get copied across
so you know this first person
um
we gave them treatment
and they had a good outcome
um so therefore we know that they are
either helped or they're of type always
recover
but we're not going to know this uh
this question mark so we're not able to
we're not able to spin down exactly
which type they are but for each person
in this simple setting we all know that
there are one of two types
okay
[Music]
okay and so yeah so
it might seem that we haven't we haven't
made any assumptions at this point but
that's not quite right
because
um because essentially we are implicitly
assuming that these uh these are well
defined
um and there are circumstances we can
think of very quickly where that
wouldn't necessarily make sense so for
example um
that they
i mean one possibility as well you know
maybe there's
actually very unbeknownst to us there
were two different versions of the
dragon so a person's potential outcome
would depend on which version they got
given
um but a more more interesting example
that's also very relevant to our current
uh
situation is that um we're supposing
that a patient's outcome only depends on
on whether they're treated or not
but you know you can imagine if if the
treatment is being given a vaccine then
you know whether or not
your outcome may not depend just on
whether or not you're vaccinated but
also whether or not the people that you
are coming into contact with are
vaccinated so and that's the
circumstance where there will be what's
called interference between the units
and so these potential outcomes would
not be well defined
okay
um
yes
that's what that's saying okay so
we we can now talk about an average
causal effect so the average causal
effect
we define is the difference between the
expected outcome that would arise if
everyone in the population were to be
given treatment
and the
outcome if everyone in the population
were to be given control
so this you can also think about this as
the difference between the proportion in
our simple setting here where with uh
binary treatment outcome this is the
difference between the proportion of
people in the population who are helped
and the proportion of people in the
population are hurt so that's going to
be that
quantity is going to take values between
minus one and one
okay so this is relevant you can think
about this as being relevant to a policy
question because the difference in the
percent proportion of people that would
recover if if everyone if we decide to
treat everyone versus if we decide to
treat nobody
a point i'm going to come back to
later is that if the average causal
effect is zero
so one way that that could happen is
that the drug does nothing and there's
nobody who's helped and there's nobody
who's hurt
so that everyone's individual causal
effect is zero but it could also happen
that in fact there are some people that
are helped and there are some people
that are hurt but those two proportions
are equal and so the average causal
effect is zero even though for some
individuals
the drag is having an effect on them
okay so if x is assigned randomly
then so
it will follow that x would be
independent of y of x zero
and x will be independent of y of x one
and that will then mean that um
this quantity so if
this is uh the proportion of people that
have one
if everyone were to receive x equals i
will be the same as
uh the proportion of people
that would have one if x was equal to y
among the people who actually get x
equals i
that's this just here we're using the
independence to get this
and then we can go from here to here
by consistency right this is simply
saying
that um
you know this is saying that
this holds because among people who
actually get x equals i their observed
outcome
is equal to the outcome they would have
had had x be equaled i
and so consequently um
the
average causal effect
uh is then going to be
um
identified as just the difference
between
um the mean outcome
uh in the
treatment arm and the mean outcome
in the control arm
this this identifies our average causal
effect
so
um so what we've seen is that if these
two independences hold
then
then our average causal effect is
identified from the conditional
distribution of y given x
okay
so let now i want to think about this a
little bit more i'm going to use the
potential outcomes uh a little bit more
um in order to think hard about this
so under randomization the relationship
to the canon functional distributions
and the observed distributions is given
like this right so essentially
um
as we saw probability y equals zero
given x equals one
is equal to probability
y of x equals one equals zero that was
the result we had on this
if i stick i equals zero
it's just saying this is equal to this
under randomization okay so this is
observed
this this is the marginal distribution
of our
joint just reached over those two
potential outcomes
okay so here
here are underlying this is the
distribution i think was being asked
about in that previous question we're
supposing that there are four types of
people in the population
um
hurt helped never recover always recover
and then um you know
in this this is the in the control arm
we're going to see the proportion of
people that recover in the control arm
will be equal to the sum of the
proportion of people of type always
recover plus the proportion of people of
type hurt the proportion of people that
recover have a good outcome in the
treatment arm that's equal to the
proportion of people who've typed help
plus some proportions of people of type
always recover
so we could think about this we could
say okay
so
if we do a very large experiment we're
going to get to know these two
margins
with arbitrary accuracy we'll get to
know these quantities i'm going to talk
about statistical inference a little bit
later but for now let's just suppose we
have a very big experiment so we get to
see these we get to know these uh these
margins
what could we then say about these
these internal cells so here i've just
written the same two by two table in two
different ways this is just
using this no notation never cover her
help always recover so never cover
remember just corresponds to this and so
on
so you could ask the question
given these margins which is what i get
to observe
what could i work out about these
internal cells
okay so
we'd like to know what we can work out
about this given that we get to see this
and and
given that under randomization we have
these
we have um
we get to know the margins from this
table
we have these two equations
linking
what we see in the control arm what we
see in the dream down linking it to
these um
these proportions
okay so if we think about this
mathematically
we can now think about well
what is this this is a distribution over
these four types we had the four types
helped hurt always recover never
recovered that's just four numbers that
sum to one
okay we could think well what does a set
of four numbers that sum to one
proportions what does that look like
so we can think about that as
okay so
just as a
um
you know if i had if i had
let's just warm up here if i had two
numbers say i have two numbers a and b
is my writing visible there i need to
make it bigger
if i have if i have two numbness a and b
actually no not possible to go full
screen but maybe i can make this a
little bigger
yeah there is another link to the
whiteboard okay so if i had two if
supposing i have two numbers a and b and
i have a plus b is equal to one
and zero less than a
b less than one
right then if i was asked to display
what's this what does the set look like
right it would look like
this right
that's the set that i would have
and if i if i went on i said okay
now supposing for a b and c
right and i'm just doing the same thing
but now
uh let's just write it like this a b c
right then
i i can write it like this a
b c
it's going to be
a little triangle
it's going to be this set here
okay um that's going to be the set of
points that satisfy that
but now we're going to take it up
um we're going to take it up one step
further
we're going
to we're going to think about four
numbers
helped
us percentage helped
hurt
always recover
and never recover
and i'm going to use the same
i'm going to use the same labeling of
the axes consistently through the rest
of the lecture
this is going to be helped
hurt
always recover
and now i'm going to i can't obviously
can't do
a 4d plot for you but what i can do is
i'm just going to show you these three
and then if you're asking about the
fourth one i'm going to say well it's
just one minus the three that i am
showing you okay so now i'm gonna have
these four points
like this
okay and so
you know this point is the happy point
where everyone is uh um helped this is
the point where unfortunately everyone
is of type hurt
this point back here
anyone want to tell me what's the point
back there
shout out
would that be
never recovered
yes everyone is of type never recover
and this is the point where everyone is
of type always recover okay
so
now i can go
and show you
this is why i couldn't go to full screen
okay so here
here is our um this is the simplex
okay
helped hurt always recover
and now
the information i get from my randomized
experiment
gives me two restrictions right because
i get to know the pro because the
proportion of people that recover in the
control arm that secret the proportion
of people of type always recover plus
hurt
and
so uh so then um i can
uh i can add these
so here's one plane
right this is
uh if i tell you the proportion of
people that are recovering the control
arm for example supposing i tell you
the pro portion recovering in the
control arm is 0.272 then you will know
that the
the
um sum of those two proportions is uh
some have always recovered plus head is
0.272 and then you'll know that i've
distributed over these four types lies
somewhere on this yellow plane
and then if i also told you say that the
proportion of people recovering on the
treatment was 0.696
you would then get you would then know
that we were
that our population
distributed over these four types by
somewhere on this blue plane
and now because these two um because
under a randomized experiment
um
the treatment group and the control
group are both coming from the same
population we could then infer what
could be done in fair
what would follow for that
are you asking are you are you asking us
yeah
function
of the outcomes under control and
outcomes under treat treatment
or at least the average treatment of
effect yeah so basically the point is
that the information from the control
arm tells us that we're on this yellow
plane
the information from the treatment down
tells us we're somewhere on the blue
plane so when we put those two pieces of
information together
we've learned that that the population
proportions must lie at the intersection
of these twos
so that's the information that we've
gained from our randomized experiment
um so the key point here is that we're
not a even though we did a randomized
experiment we're not able in general to
know the exact distribution over these
four types
it could be anywhere along this line but
it's also the case that every one of
these distributions along this line will
have the same value for the average
causal effect okay that's you can sort
of see that from
from um
you know middle school arithmetic
uh that if i'm telling you the sum of
these have helped plus always recover
and the sum of her plus always recover
then when we take the difference between
those two that's helped minus hurt
so it's not surprising that this uh
whatever that
whatev although we can't pin down
exactly the distribution of these four
types all the possible distributions
over these four types will share in
common that they correspond to exactly
the same value of the average causal
effect the difference between the
proportion helped and heck
okay
any questions about that before i go on
yeah can you hear me oh yep okay great
um
so this is an interesting like geometric
way of seeing this i have two quiet
questions
the first is um
i think i i don't see it in the
geometric picture that you have but i
believe
that i can estimate
any linear function not just
outcome minus
you know treatment under outcome
instrument under clear outcome under
treatment minus outcome under control
troll my first question is what's the
geometric way to see that is there some
hyper plane going
or thought or what yeah what's the
geometric way to see that in the picture
that you have here and the second thing
is this relies a lot on binary
uh
out
comes is there a similar geometric thing
that you have in your head
before non-binary out out
comes
yes so
uh going back to your first question
um
yeah so i mean i think if we look at the
proof that was here
like you can see that if if you put in
here
um
if you were to take any the expectation
of a linear combination of these two
things
obviously we could go through we could
pull out those um so i don't i don't
necessarily have a way immediate way to
see that in terms of this picture
um
the
yeah so i i will also say this is
um this is specific here to binary
outcomes
um
but yeah my motivation for doing this is
i want to this is going i want to be
able to show you what happens when we do
do deal with instrumental variables
and um
yes as you can see when we're thinking
um in terms of these potential outcomes
um
already even just with binary things
there are enough quant the number of
quantities we have quite a lot of
quantities to think about and keeping
things to binary allows us to visualize
everything that is here
any other questions
okay great
okay um
you see it can you clarify the model for
individual outcome probabilities in this
framework
yes so so at the simplest level here
each individual just has it's just of a
certain type so it's it's sort of
we could say it's like a calvinist it's
almost a calvinist view that there's
just a big book and written down in that
book
sometimes called the full science table
just is the outcome
so
the so
um
essentially the
the we have a distribution here because
we might be thinking about this these
people as being in some large population
and then we're going to um the people in
our study are going to be randomly
selected from that population i'll come
back to that point a little bit more
because there was also some questions
about finite population influence which
i i will also say a little bit about
okay um
but but yeah i think actually just to
add a comment here i think it's
important to say the idea is the
potential outcomes we have a
distribution of potential outcomes and
then the realized outcome is then a
deterministic function of the treatment
we decide to give someone and their
potential outcomes
just another clarification question
are we thinking of random variable y as
the outcome for a particular individual
or
a randomly chosen individual what does
it depend on
well yeah i think you could you can
think about it either way before i
choose the individual it's around them
uh before i choose an individual and
decide what treatment to give them
then
it's a random variable depending both on
which individual i choose and depending
on what treatment i decide to give to
them
so there were some
questions somebody sent me a message
asking about how this connected to
finite population influence and finite
population influence
there is a way of thinking about this
framework where we just think about set
of people as fixed
so we think about the potential outcomes
as constants that are specific to the
people that are in you know where we're
only interested in a very specific uh
population maybe it's an endangered
species and there are only you know 80
white rhinos left so there's just a
fixed population there is no
superpopulation that it's meaningful to
talk about
and in that case
uh we would think about the potential
outcomes as fixed and then the
randomness is arising from
uh um
over hypothetical replications of our
experiment which individuals we're
deciding to assign to treating versus
assigned to control
okay
okay
okay so here i just in terms of the
mathematical objects that we've got
we've got a distribution over potential
outcomes and then we've got our observed
data which under randomization
um our observed data
this is the observed data in the control
arm observed data in the treatment down
will be equal to the margins of this
joint distribution
okay and we've seen
this this is a pretty simple
set up here we just have these four
types
and then we get to see these two uh
margins of this particular two by two
table
okay and what i've just shown you here
was given a particular observed
distribution we can go back and ask
what's the set of all possible counter
factual distributions what's the set of
distributions
uh over counter factors um
over these four types that are
compatible with a particular observed
distribution and that corresponds to
this line segment that we've got here
okay so that's randomized experiments
from a potential outcome framework in
this very simple setting
what about if i have
what about if i have an observational
study
okay so now i want us to think for a
second like uh
a legal scholar or a lawyer basically
okay so for example suppose that
suppose that we've got this this data
this is now not from a randomized
experiment
this is from an observational study
and in this observational study
um you know
that some people got placebos some
people got drug
and then these are the uh outcomes now
supposing that you're
a lawyer for the
drug company
and you want to
sort of come up with a story relating to
this data that makes
the drug look as good as possible
so we say here what's the largest
proportion of people of type help that
we could have
if i look at this data
okay so
so again think like the the drug company
lawyer these people here they got the
drug and they lived
so we know
logically they either have to be of type
help or of type
always recover
but if we're going to be
thinking like the law of the drug
company what we're obviously going to
say well all of these people are type
help right this is a this is a miracle
drug they wouldn't uh they wouldn't
still be here if uh if they hadn't um
had a great drug so all of these people
are we're going to claim of time helped
and likewise these people here
who are either um helped or never
recover
we're going to make the same claims
we're going to say that all of these
people it's tragedy
all of these people here if only they'd
had our drug they'd all still be
alive these people over here we're going
to have to you know it's a little harder
right these people got our drug and they
died so what we're going to claim about
them
will be the natural thing to claim
thinking like a drug company lawyer
they were doomed yeah i mean they got
our miracle dragon they still died so
obviously absolutely nothing we can do
about them they're all of type never
cover
the people over here
they got the placebo and somehow they're
still alive
so obviously these people are just you
know
bulletproof it's just they're obviously
completely indestructible these are all
of type boys recover
so essentially
thinking if we're trying to make the
drug look as good as possible we're
going to argue that the proportion of
people of type helped is .65 it's these
people plus these people
and we're going to claim that
no one's hurt right because remember we
should we we
argued that these people were doomed
they were never recovering these people
type always recover so there's no one
who's hurt
so
if we're trying to make the drug look as
good as possible then the average causal
effect here is
is
0.65 because at 0.65 percent of people
are helped and no one's hurt
but then
so that's our maximum value for the ac
but now if we turn it around if we're
trying to if we're now arguing that this
is a very damaging terrible drug
we're going to turn things around
we're going to now claim that all of
these people are quite hurt
we're going to claim these people of
type and never recover and these people
of type always recover so we'll end up
with
um we'll end up with a minimum value of
the average causal effect of minus 0.35
and so
um yeah so just to be clear if you
looked at this data it has the same
um
conditional distributions as the data
set that we looked before looked at
before which is when we looked at the
randomized experiment where we could
identify the average forceful effect
um
so
uh
yeah so so you can think about this as
sort of a good news bad news scenario so
before we saw any data the possible
range of values for the average causal
effect was minus one to one so the good
news is we've cut the range in half
based on this observational study
the bad news is that the uh the
the range of our bounds is still one
and so that also means that uh in
general our bounds are always going to
that will always hold so our bounds will
in general always include
zero sort of in general
we can say this so if we don't know if
we don't have randomization what can we
infer about the subset of distribution
this is what we can infer
we can infer that the average causal
effect lies between these two quantities
but these two quantities the difference
between these two
will always be one
okay what further information could we
obtain
so here i'm going to ask a question that
may seem a bit crazy at this point
because you might say well wait a second
you've already shown me
that this you know that we can't work
out whether or not the average causal
effect is uh greater than zero or less
than zero why why are we caring about
this
why why do you persist
um
but well hopefully i'll motivate that in
the in the in the second edges so here
suppose
suppose that we now do
um
suppose that we now take
um
we could now think about our observed
data
as coming from a one-way table
so here for example the people who have
x equals zero and y equals zero
then
you know okay so
we get to know their potential outcomes
under uh x equals zero under control we
know that's zero
we don't know their outcome under
treatment
so our observed outcome over here is the
sum of these two
uh
events
here i've colored these to indicate this
is this is the only thing that's
changing on this row between this and
this is that we don't know what would
happen under
under uh treatment
likewise we can do the same for each one
of these observed cells
so we could we could also rewrite this
table like this right so i could say
so this is just the proportion of people
who have x equals zero
and r of type never recover this is a
proportion of people who have x equals 0
and
r of type helped and so on so i can
rewrite the table like this
okay
so why is that helpful well it means
that now we can ask the same question
that we had before so i'm going to give
give you an observed distribution but
now this is an observed distribution
from an observational study
we're going to think about what's the
set of
what's the set of uh counterfactual
distributions that are compatible with
that observed data
okay so and in particular what we really
care about is the distribution of those
four types
that map to a given observed
distribution okay so we're given the
observed distribution x y
so if you like we're given this margin
and what we really care about is the
possible distributions over these four
types helped hurt always recover never
recover
okay so i'm going to claim so first for
every proportion these are proportions
so we get a free lower bound no problem
they're all bounded below by zero
so i'm going to claim we can also get an
upper bound
so i claim in particular
that
this quantity that the that the um
proportion of people have type helped um
is at most
probability x
the proportion of people with x equals
zero y equals zero plus the proportion
of people with x equals one and y equals
one
okay so can anyone see a simple argument
why that holds based on this table
so to make it concrete supposing that
five percent of populations in the first
row and ten percent is in the bottom row
i'm claiming that proportion help can be
at most fifteen percent why why would
that hold
the eight sheets are just in those two
rows yeah exactly the only people of
type help are on those rows the other
rows have no one-of-type help so the
most anyone that's have typed help
either shows up on the first row or the
fourth row
so the largest i mean it's possible that
it's certainly possible proportionality
is less than this but it can be no more
than this
and we get bounds then for all of these
four types you can do the same thing
exactly the same logic
we get upper bounds on hurt never cover
always recover
okay
but we're not quite done yet
because
we can also get bounds on the marginals
so for example if i look at this guy
this is the proportion of people of type
hurt plus always recover that's the uh
the marginal
uh probability
for the outcome under x equals zero
that's one that's equal to proportion
people have hurt plus always recover
so so
i'm going to claim that if we look at
that so if you ask me about proportion
hurt plus always recover
this guy
that is lower bounded by this number
okay so i'm claiming that that
there that the proportion of people of
type who are of type hurt or of type
always recover
can be no less than this
you can probably see the argument for
that is that well everyone in this row
everyone in that row
is of type hurt
words of type always recover so if i
tell you that you know 20 percent of
people are in that this uh this
probability is 20
you know that the proportion of people
of type hurt or always recoveries at
least 20
couldn't be any less than that because
everyone in that row is of that type so
we get a lower bound
and we can also get an upper bound
because although there are some people
of type hurt or always recovering those
in rows two three and four
in the first row there's no one of type
hurt or always recover so we've got an
upper bound
uh on this proportion if i tell you this
is you know
if i tell you this is fifty percent
then you know okay fifty percent
population is not of type hurt always
recover so proportion of type hurt or
always recover can be no greater than 1
minus 50 or 50
okay
so that now means that we've now got six
pairs of parallel planes
which if you just give me a second i
will now show you
uh hold on
just a second
and
this looks like it
to any windows
all right
sorry about this
my computer is being slow here
okay got it
okay
let me take you through this give me a
second
okay
this is just visualizing what we what
we've got here so we had six
six pairs of bounds
six pairs of parallel planes
okay so
so just to
put it all together we've got here
we've got upper and lower bounds on uh
each of the joint probabilities and we
also have upper and lower bounds on the
mountains
so here are here's a simplex
right uh there's one plane that i'm not
showing you here because um
if i put it in
you can't see anything it's the one on
the front
so those are the lower bounds
that we see here the purple ones are
these lower bounds
and now i'm going to show you what these
bounds look like for the very simple
case just because it's easier to
visualize where all of these observe
proportions of 0.25
okay so then we're then going to have
so we'll have upper and lower bounds for
helped
okay so this is help this is the help
axis this is the upper bound this is the
lower bound
i have upper and lower bounds
on the hurt axis
this is the upper bound this is the
lower bound
we're going to have
upper and lower bounds on always recover
this is the upper bound lower bound is
this plane
and we're going to also have upper and
lower bounds you never recover
right this is the upper bound for never
recover
the lower bound is this face of the
simplex i've taken off so we can see
what's going on
okay so that's the first four sets of
parallel planes
then we've got two more which are the
bounds on the margins
so i'll show you those bounds
so here are the upper lower bounds on
always recover plus
um hurt
this is uh
you said like the planes that we saw
before this is always recover plus hurt
the um upper bound always recover plus
hurt the lower bound
and we get the same thing for always
recover plus
helped
okay and so
the
set of possible distributions that we
would have
then corresponds to the little area
that's inside here
which
sort of here here's one i prepared
earlier this was for the observational
study data that we saw before
it's the same shape um
it's a dodecahedron but it's probably
not what you think of when you think of
a dodecahedron this is a kind of less
famous one this is not the platonic
solid this is a it's less famous cousin
the rhombic dodecahedron
uh where you can see some points have
got three have three edges meeting at a
point others have four so it's not
it's not the it's not the one you think
of which has pentagons faces
okay
so i've got two minutes left here before
coffee break and i've got basically i
think about two slides left to go here
or two slides after which we can take a
break
okay so this is the shape that we've now
worked out so what have we done we
started off with data from this
observational study and we've now taken
that data and we've worked out that the
possible distributions over these four
types has to live inside this
this shape
okay
and we could now if we wanted to know
about the average causal effect
we could then flip this
shape over essentially project out
always recover and just look at helped
and hurt
so this is just all i'm doing is uh
taking this shape and turning it over
so now this is help this is hurt and
sort of always recovers going into the
screen
and i can see this is the projection
and we have the same kind of not
terribly exciting story where we've
worked out that um the
we have a distribution where proportion
hurt is 0.35 and proportion help to zero
and we've got another distribution where
proportion helped is 0.65 and proportion
hert is zero
so
our bounds on the average causal effect
are going to straddle zero so you know
might not seem terribly helpful
but we're going to see actually that the
work we've done here and working out
what this set is
is going to turn out to be useful um
when we look at instrumental variables
okay so here's the summary
we've
causal contrast compare the potential
outcomes of the same units
under different treatments
conceptually across different possible
worlds for each observed
data point um
each unit one outcome will be actual and
the other will be counterfactual so
there are
cases in psychology there are some
situations where you can do crossover
designs where maybe you do get to see
those potential outcomes but the whole
focus of
causal influence in statistics is the
situation where uh where we have this
fundamental problem of causal influence
where we can only see one of them
a really great thing about this is it
allows causation
which you know is something that uh
people all the way back to democritus
thought was really interesting and
uh uh curious and intriguing and you can
you know write popular books that sell
very well
um
but what we've shown here you may or may
not realize our little table reduced
this to missing data
which is something that
you know
uh is of great interest to statisticians
and to some other people but it's not
quite as
it's not quite as uh as exciting as
causation but i don't think uh
maybe there's probably some greek
philosophers say that you know if i
could fill in that missing data
i'd that that would be great um but but
basically
the the the the reduction in excitement
when we go from causation to missing
data that to me that shows that there's
conceptual progress
i'm taking something people think is
mysterious and reduced it to something
people think is a little bit boring
perhaps mistakenly but uh but even so
we saw the ac is identified
if we have this independence
randomization of treatment implies that
and then
without independence the ac is not
identified and cannot be bounded away
from zero and i'll stop there
sorry for running over a little bit
thank you there's one question in the
zoom that just came up it's
quite low maybe you've agreed
in the potential outcome framework how
do we understand the semantics of
interventions there
is a logically causal inference for
so-called non-manipulable variables of
individuals gender raised genetic
answers throughout manchester et cetera
framework seems to take different
stances from the graph
yeah so i'll take two con there are two
basic comments on that one is i i sort
of see that that's a very good point
which is that the graphical framework as
it is often presented i don't think it
has to be presented like this but as it
is often presented
uh and certainly sort of in the paradigm
examples if you you know that pearl
talks about he um
there's the suggestion that we have a
set of equations and it's po and that
conceptually it's well defined to
intervene on any given equation
um i think it's an
advantage of the um the potential
outcome framework that
that before that basically researchers
have to you know before you start off
you have to spend time thinking about
before you write down your model you
have to convince people those potential
outcome variables are well defined and
you have to sort of go through the the
uh trial by ordeal that um anyone that
start in you know starts talking about
um
counterfactuals has to do you have to
sort of
make us an argument to say that that's a
well-defined quantity that you're
discussing
and i actually think that's right
because i think in a lot of applied and
empirical work that the hard work
a lot of the hard work goes into
uh very precisely trying to define what
it is that you're talking about in terms
of your intervention so you know if we
say something like what's the effect of
childhood what's the effect of education
on earnings
and then we say something like oh well
you know
uh let's have an intervention where we
increase the number of uh years of
education by one
we can think about a lot of different
ways that that could be implemented we
could send start people in school
earlier
we could um
we could sort of uh prevent them from
leaving school at the other end
we could
drag people back to school after they've
left
those interventions that we you know i
think it's very reasonable to think will
all lead to very different
outcomes and often a lot of the work
hard work that goes in in uh testing
hypotheses
uh occurs in trying to come up with a
precise formulation of what exactly is
intervention and i think the potential
outcome framework forces people
or at least should force people to think
carefully about what exactly are the
potential outcomes they're talking about
having said that you know there were
papers that were written uh one of the
papers on the i think the paper that
introduced the term reuben causal model
by
holland
essentially said that there were you
know that it would be impossible to
think about uh um uh
you know that we couldn't possibly think
about causal effects of of gender or
race because these are sort of intrinsic
qualities of the unit and we couldn't
imagine what it would be to have
for those to change um
and
uh this falls into what i call the sort
of the the first law of uh
of empirical
um
work which is that whenever a
philosopher says it's impossible to work
something out then almost certainly
within a short period of time
um some clever experimentalists will
come up with a way whereby they can come
up with an experiment that
you know uh gets around
for practical purposes gets around that
particular uh um objection and i think
exactly that happened with the with
these objections um
saying that we couldn't we couldn't uh
get effects of um
uh of uh
of gender or race that people did very
quickly did experiments where they
you know created populations of cvs
and then randomly assigned names to them
um
or you know they did
orchestra editions where they suddenly
said why don't we just not have people
audition for the part
in the orchestra behind a curtain
or you know airbnb
created
you know created
fictitious customers that then asked
to whether they could stay in stay at
various hosts houses
and then they could randomly assign they
were able to create populations
hypothetical populations to determine
whether or not people were being
discriminated against so yes of course a
statistic you know paul holland might
still respond by saying oh but that's
not truly changing the the um the the
gender of the people that are in there
that are in our study but i think for
all practical purposes it is getting at
a causal effect um and so yeah so
my answer is essentially
um
that uh
the answer is i think it's the strength
of the potential outcome framework that
the bar
for talking about interventions is set a
bit higher and that there you can talk
about causal effects for some
interventions without feeling obligated
to say that you know what it is to
intervene on everything
i think that's a
strength on the other hand i i disagree
with people
um who've who have said
you know that there's no way to get a
certain causal effects because i think
clever experiments can always
get interesting aspects of um of causal
effects
uh for things even if if
you know
initially we think they're not
manipulable i'll answer your question
okay great let's take a break 25 minutes
thank you very much thomas and we'll
read today at 11 a.m pacific time great
can i still ask
is is
thomas can you still hear hear hear me
here yes
um do you mind if i ask you a question
certainly not provided i i i i possibly
postpone answering if i if it looks like
it's going to
prevent me getting coffee sure sure um
well then i'll say it and then you know
do whatever you uh
want
um so my question is
uh two two parts the first is like
these these bounds based on like knowing
the
the you know
different marginals here
bounds on the joint this like poly
taupe that you have yeah my first
question is do people use this in like
research papers because to me it seems
like it's
like if i just looked at like the volume
i mean this is a weird measure to look
at but the volume didn't go down that
much
um so i'm wondering you know is this
thing that
is for us to understand in our heads or
do people actually do empiricists use
this and the second question i have is
um
it seems to heavily rely on binary uh
out
comes and i'm wondering if there's a
meaningful extension uh to the real
valued uh out out comes
okay so two-part uh reply to that so one
part here is
um
so so people don't often don't so
implicitly yes so essentially these
politics i'm going to show you this is a
bit of a plot spoiler but essentially
i'm going to show you that these
polytopes
underlie the bulky pearl bounds
in for instruments um for computing
bounds on
uh on average causal effects in
instrumental variable setting and i'll
show that in fact this way of thinking
about it
lets you come up with bounds for more
general uh situations
than were originally considered by pearl
and there is work that that instrumental
variable line of work
has been extended also to think about
um
has been extended further in other ways
but um yeah i think you can
you can extend to having
so it is the case that the getting these
bounds does depend on the the response
living in a
bounded space i think if the response is
unbounded you don't get um
you you don't get uh you know
interesting results um it's
um
uh in terms of extensions i think the
thing which is hardest is that to do
this non-parametrically in the case
where
treatment is
um continuous
um but so continuous response continuous
but bounded response can be taken into
account it can be done reasonably
um continuous unbounded response i think
uh is certainly a limitation to this
method
awesome uh
thanks uh i look forward to seeing uh
the rest of it and i'll let you get your
coffee excellent thank you thanks
you